Konzentriert und vorausschauend,
sich Schritt für Schritt nach oben arbeitend –
das ist es, was Pierre Zissel
am Klettern fasziniert.
Und genau so wünscht er sich
eigentlich die deutsche Politik.
Deshalb ist wählen gehen für den
22-Jährigen ein Muss.
Jede junge Stimme ist wichtig,
findet Pierre.
Die Jungen seien ohnehin zu wenig vertreten.
Unsere Generation hat keine Lobby.
Das ist, denke ich, das Problem.
Also, natürlich hat jetzt auch nicht
die ältere Generation irgendwie eine Lobby,
aber letztendlich sind aber doch die
Interessen vieler älterer Menschen
in Deutschland institutionell
besser repräsentiert
als die Interessen junger Menschen.
Tatsächlich sind im Deutschen Bundestag
nicht mal ein Prozent
der Abgeordneten unter 30.
Auch die Wähler sind meist älter – und
stimmen öfter für konservative Parteien.
In Erfurt, wo Pierre wohnt, ist jeder fünfte
Bewohner über 65 – Tendenz steigend.
Pierre hat oft das Gefühl, dass es
in der Politik zu wenig darum geht,
was junge Leute brauchen.
Gemerkt hat der Student das etwa
in der Pandemie,
als viele seiner Kommilitonen plötzlich
Existenzängste hatten.
Auch ich habe meinen Nebenjob verloren
zum Beispiel in der Gastronomie.
Da kenne ich auch einige …
viele Menschen, die dadurch, dass sie den
Nebenjob verloren haben,
dann auch im Bildungsweg dann ‘nen
erheblichen Einschnitt bekommen haben.
Viele haben sogar das Studium
unterbrochen oder gar abgebrochen,
und da wird eben sehr wenig
drüber gesprochen.
In den vergangenen 18 Monaten
war Pierre viel zu Hause.
Das Studium fand meist nur
übers Internet statt,
seine Band tritt nicht mehr auf.
Stattdessen: Gitarren-Übungen im
WG-Zimmer.
Pierre sagt, viele seiner Freunde seien
jetzt vor der Bundestagswahl
enttäuscht von der Politik und den Parteien.
Das nehme ich zumindest in
meiner Generation sehr viel wahr,
dass sehr viel Politikverdrossenheit
stattfindet.
Da sehe ich die Rolle meiner Generation
gerade auch so ein bisschen,
dass wir von außen Druck ausüben,
denn die Parteien sind
innerhalb sehr statisch.
Also, man muss ‘nen sehr langen Weg
gehen, von Ortsverein über Plakate kleben,
bis man wirklich auch selbst merkt, dass man
Entscheidungen mit beeinflussen kann –
und das frustriert viele junge Menschen.
Seinen Platz sieht Pierre deshalb
außerhalb der Parteien.
Seit zwei Jahren engagiert er sich
bei Fridays for Future.
Jede Woche treffen sich die Klima-Aktivisten.
Gerade bereiten sie eine Demonstration vor,
die kurz vor der Wahl stattfinden soll.
Die Bundestagswahl 2021 wird auf jeden Fall
'ne richtungsweisende Wahl sein,
das ist ganz klar.
Die nächste Legislatur wird ohne Zweifel
darüber entscheiden,
ob Deutschland die selbst gesetzten
Klimaziele aus dem Pariser Klimaabkommen
einhalten kann – sprich ob wir unseren Teil
dazu beitragen können,
dass das 1,5-Grad-Ziel eingehalten wird.
Die Zeit dränge.
Die Politik habe noch immer nicht verstanden,
was junge Klimaschützer wie ihn umtreibt.
Ich würde fast sagen: ein Stück weit Panik.
Denn wir haben …
wir sehen auf der ganzen Welt
Überflutungskatastrophen,
nicht erst seit diesem Jahr.
Wir sehen Hitzewellen, Dürreperioden,
Waldbrände, auch nicht erst seit diesem Jahr.
Wir sehen unzählige Tierarten,
die nacheinander aussterben
und irgendwie juckt es dann doch keinen.
Und wir rasen gerade wirklich mit ‘nem
lachenden Gesicht auf den Abgrund zu.
Dass die nächste Regierung das Ruder
noch herumreißt, glaubt Pierre nicht.
Er rechnet damit, auch nach der Wahl fürs
Klima auf die Straße gehen zu müssen.